One activity that helps people
warm up in the diverge stage
is the crazy eights.
You give everyone a sheet of paper, and
you ask them to fold it three times to
create eight different rectangles, then,
in each rectangle,
you put one idea related to the product.
Now, you only have five
minutes to do this activity.
So you go as quickly as possible,
and you try and
push yourself to put something
in every single box.
Now, this activity can be a little
bit intimidating to people who aren't
as designers.
So here are a few tips for
what you can do.
First, it's a good idea
to remind yourself and
the team about common UI elements.
Most UI components are very basic
shapes, like rectangles and circles.
And they can be drawn pretty easily.
You might remind your team of some of
those shapes, like list, and icons, and
buttons, and titles.
You might also just spend a few
minutes looking at mobile patterns, so
that way you can check out
what others have done.
You might also download free mobile or
web UI kits.
So that way you can go through
some of those design components.
Just be sure not to leave these
resources up during an activity,
because the focus should
be on sketching ideas.
All right, now it's your turn.
Set a timer for five minutes and
sketch eight ideas you have that are
related to the Super Duper Shopping App.
Now, keep in mind the activity
that you did with the Golden Path.
And remember that main user journey or
that story that you created.
Once you've completed this activity,
check this box to continue.